turning now to our candid conversation
with musician Amanda shires she was on
the verge of quitting music she said
when she made her latest album It's
called take it like a man now it's being
held by critics as one of country's best
recent albums she's very proud of this
work the New York Times says quote
here's a spirit of Outlaw country in
2022 a Fearless woman Gathering all her
strength and belting out her truths with
a poet's diction and a bird of Praise
voices I like that awesome I like that
too in addition to her acclaimed solo
work chars is also known for founding
the all-female super group The High
women with Brandy Carlisle maren Morris
and Natalie him Natalie himby all
superstars in their own were in their
own right as well as her as well as her
work with her husband's band that's
Jason Isbell and the 400 unit Nate and I
recently sat down with shires to discuss
her album marriage and motherhood Tony
was off because he had their own nut
that's the only reason why he wasn't
here but here's that interview
I want to talk about your music because
you have said everything on this record
is autobiographical you didn't hold
anything back so what was your thought
process what was your mind State when
you were writing well I at first was
when I was writing I was like the worst
that could happen is I don't like the
song and nobody has to hear it and then
I'll write something that I like or feel
comfortable with or even want to
investigate in the studio you sing about
things that are struggles most people
will not admit to even within your
marriage right were there difficult
times when you were writing or even
recording oh definitely you know I feel
like the more that we talk about these
things like my grandparents were married
forever and they said marriage is hard
but I never understood what that was but
it also feels like if you talk about
marriage you're doing something
um
I don't know unfair to them yeah I must
have happened in society yeah it's too
personal yeah it feels like cheating or
betraying yeah if you talk about it but
I think it's more healthy it's
therapeutic I do think it's therapeutic
you're of course married to Jason Isbell
and you you were very candid about
problems that you all had had in your
marriage and he encouraged you to
release a song that could be could be
very vulnerable for people who are
listening that's kind of the job though
in the end I was I was wasn't sure I
wanted to answer questions about it and
his advice was you don't have to or you
can tell it from your side because it is
you know it's your story and I think the
job though is that writers say the hard
thing so other people can have language
for those hard things
I think I was worried about the
questions and then
about
um
criticisms in and not in the music
musical sense but in the way that I was
talking about
my marriage with my personal life yeah
my personal life but at the same time it
feels like the pressure's off to
maintain the always
Shiny Happy married people it's not
always sunshine and rainbow no and
people don't talk about it and then if
that normal you don't know if you're
supposed to keep going through the hard
times to make it through some yeah
potential hopeful you come out on the
other side maybe you do are you and
Jason okay today can we today yes we are
yes okay I'm glad but I'm so fascinated
Amanda by your voice I I don't even know
how to describe it and maybe that's the
point that you can't really be
pigeonholed into any kind of genre
right do you feel that
um the voice thing is part of the reason
I almost quit because one person told me
let's go more note
but that's okay we've forgotten about
that I'm insulted but it's all good uh I
don't know how to describe it except for
I don't know I learned to play violin
first yeah it's beautifully unique well
thank you and that's okay to describe it
yeah beautifully it sounds a little bit
like
uh braggy beautifully unique
you've earned the right to say that
exactly there are people that are
beginning their Journey young teenagers
that are looking at maybe marriage or
getting into the music industry trying
to figure out who they are what they
want to do
what advice do you have for them I I
think the the thing that worked for me a
lot was showed up on time and when
people say be a team player it's not as
much about being a team player as it is
understanding group dynamics like
understanding a person is going through
something that you don't know what
they're going through and and you are as
well but to to kind of give Grace in the
in the situation of humans and the other
thing is always pack a swimsuit
yeah you never know are you ready you
never knew about what swimming
there could be a pool there could be a
hot tub I like that I like that okay
that's really good I'm gonna remember
Amanda shires that always packs always
pack a swimsuits and talk to us about
being a mom you have a young daughter
Mercy what is the message you're sending
to her that whatever thing she falls in
love with and um
is passionate about she should do and
then if she should
find something wrong in the world she
should change it if she can
but I just think that you are so cool
and your voice is so beautiful and I
can't wait for us to be blessed with
your performance today thank you thank
you well thank you so much I'm honored
we were honored stay with us for
Amanda's performance of take it like a
man that's the title track of her recent
album that's coming right up when we
spoke with songwriter Amanda shires
about her latest album she told us that
the title track take it like a man means
everything to her she says that it's
about love and the consequences of your
choices here's her performance of that
song right here in the studio
[Music]
Birdsong everywhere
a lark in the shower
from the night to the morning
[Music]
s
[Music]
Shook and quivering
oh who I could have could
oh I could have grown
I was scared by your wrist I know what
the cost is consequence
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Falls of Fascinations
the sky was leaking night
girl
your eyes do
do that shipwreck expression
I need more words for food
trailing in the tree
the way I measure you
fractured
13s
that you give when you want me to go
falling further in Falcon's way
I know what the cost is in the octaves
of consequence
I know the cost of life is
[Music]
I know I could take it like a bender
and uh
did she say Amanda
I just said tonight did she say Amanda
like Amanda oh oh I miss that as well I
missed that very nice Amanda shires
thank you